of the books that you've written Anna
how many had traditional Publishers and
how many were self-published
six were traditionally published and
then I've done
two between two and five I never know
what to count as a book when I can put I
you know I put out a journal two weeks
ago like does that count but I did six
traditionally published and the rest I
published myself
is it worth it to self-publish a
thousand percent it is
um you need experts you need help
everybody Malcolm Gladwell has an editor
you need an editor
um you need a book designer you need
help doing the launch or maybe you're
just really good at research and you can
figure out I have met people who have
done Exquisite launches without having
any experience but most people are going
to need help
how realistic is it for most Riders to
land a traditional publishing deal
it's really really hard to get a
traditional publishing deal now when I
first got in it was very different now
the statistic that I hear is two out of
every 10 000 book proposals submitted to
Big Five publisher cell those are agent
represented
um if Publishers are not interested alas
in talent and unique ideas and amazing
Stories and it's not because they're
terrible people they're interested in
what's going to sell which is why the
people with all the following the people
with the big newsletter list the
celebrities that's who gets deals now
it's really not for that diamond in the
rough great idea
should it be a pageant of honor to have
rejection letters you know the whole oh
I'm going to paper my wall you know my
bathroom with all my rejection letters
and that just shows like I'm gonna keep
going is that really a badge of honor
I'm not a fan of Gatekeepers my life got
so good when I stopped putting myself
out there to say like hey am I good
enough
um I take rejection really hard if other
people don't and they want to keep going
I mean that being said the people I know
who are successful are just the ones who
got up over and over and over again
success as a writer success is any sort
of creative I I actually don't think
it's about Talent it's about tenacity
it's about being willing to you know
being able to take getting knocked down
and getting back up again but I'd much
rather live in a world without
Gatekeepers where I can just make it
happen
what should a new author expect from
their publisher
very little
um I think that um
we all go into a traditional publishing
deal thinking that our publisher is
really behind us and I always liken it
to
um you know your filmmaker and your
writing and directing and scarring
producing and and a studio gives you all
this money and you go and you make your
movie and they're like yes this is so
awesome this is going so great and then
it's the release day and no one from the
studio calls you back and you're like
but I don't understand you gave me money
we were in this together and then it's
just like
that's what it's like when you publish a
book you think because they've been with
you the whole time you think they're in
it with you and I again if you're
Glennon Doyle you're JK Rowling I'm sure
they are with the rest of us you just
are sort of like jumping off the diving
board alone so you better we all heard
that going in and thought it would be
different
um but even I've interviewed Robert
Greene like the one of the most
successful writers of all time he's like
your publisher does nothing for you
given a choice would you rather
self-publish or have a publishing deal I
would rather publish myself over a
publishing deal any day because I have
published I have had books come out
where I hated the cover I hated the
title I hated sections of it and I was
basically giving away all my power for
absolutely nothing in return
um
that being said I mean like I haven't
had a big publisher come along and say
Here's a million dollars to write
whatever book you want it hasn't
happened I haven't been put to the test
but um I'm pretty I feel pretty safe
saying
um I will never traditionally publish
again
okay so that being said what are the
disadvantages of self-publishing
um
the disadvantage of self-publishing is
if you don't have people around you who
know what they're doing you're basically
going to put out a lesser product it's
not going to be written well it's not
going to be edited well it's not going
to have a great cover it's not going to
have all the things but if you uh want
to hire people to do professionals to do
all of that stuff it's going to look the
same as a traditionally published book
the other thing is these Publishers have
so many different divisions nobody knows
like in live in is a division of Harper
Collins like no if you make up a name of
a Publishing Company nobody knows that
that's a big one or yours
okay so suppose me Karen wants to write
a book okay
I'm going to start my own LLC as a
publishing company is that correct
um yeah you actually I'm not a lawyer
but sure I don't know that you actually
need an LLC you can just make up a name
you go to a website called My
identifiers.com which is Bowker they
they give out all the ISBN numbers so
you basically go I think it's a hundred
dollars you buy an ISBN and you fill in
the name of the publisher and that's
what's going to go out a lot of people
screw that up and it'll say like create
space or KDP or independently published
you can make up you can make name it
after cat and make that your publishing
company and that's what's going to come
up okay so yeah again check with your
attorney uh but we don't know LLC or not
but you can go and get yours you said
it's an ISBN yeah okay International
standard book number and then you can
just fill in a name that you make up
make sure that someone else doesn't
already have that name do they run a
check don't even know I don't know okay
and then there you go you're you're now
a publisher yeah and now you need your
book yeah so is that the first step
I think ISBN comes down the line the
first step is have your elevator pitch
and I actually do have you can go to
bookelevatorpitch.com and I'll give you
this template it's my book is for blank
so that they can blank and that is your
step fill that out print it put it on
your wall put it everywhere remember
like your book is not about you it's
about them you're a reader so never
forget that
why is it important for an author to
realize no one cares about their book
it's important because
um as the author you have to make your
book fit into what's going on in the
world it's not news to anyone
when a book comes out so you know if
you're trying to get on mainstream media
which while it doesn't sell books is
really awesome promotion and social
proof and all of those things instead of
going hey news show my book is out think
how does this fit into the news when I
had my book make your mess your Memoir
come out July of 2020 Global pandemic a
book on writing is not news to anybody
but I so it was up to me to say how do I
make this news so I looked up statistics
about depression are at an all-time high
the numbers are terrible then I looked
up does writing help with depression
found numerous studies that said it I
wrote a press release and I said this is
the this is the news the depression
statistics are terrible writing helps
with depression this author Anna David
is available to speak about it and I got
that too good morning America and from
that I got a four minute segment on Good
Morning America there was nothing in my
book about writing helps heal depression
but it didn't matter that's what I
talked on the show about and the whole
time it said like New York Times
best-selling author of make your mess
your Memoir so it was imperative upon
you as the author to figure out where
your book fits into the news and not
think that your book is news in itself
and then reach out to the appropriate
outfit yeah pitching yourself yeah I can
talk a little bit about how to do that
yeah that'd be great so in order to get
media attention definitely start with
how is my book newsworthy try to find
studies try to find statistics try to
find Bookers if you put in Good Morning
America Booker a bunch of people's
linkedins are going to come up their
information is readily accessible there
are websites like mukrak and
Hunter IO
um you can find them on LinkedIn there
are ways to find out people's email
addresses the other thing you can do is
subscribe to Hero which is short for
help a reporter out and they send out
three emails a day and it's everybody
from like your mom's blog to the New
York Times They are looking for sources
and they'll say I'm looking for sources
to speak about depression about
addiction about movies about writing
whatever it is they send out three
emails a day look through the emails and
when something comes up that is relevant
for your topic you are an expert if
you're writing a book on a topic you're
an expert so reach out to that
journalist with the pitch on why you
should be in that story those are the
two best ways to get media attention